Okay, here's an example of a decision problem that comes up in social network analysis
and that's the clique problem.
Remember clique is a set of nodes in a network that are all pairwise connected--
everybody in the group knows everybody else in the group.
We were given a graph G and a number k, let's say 4, and we're asked--is there a clique of size k in G.
So remember clique is a connective set of nodes--so for example 1, 3, 4 is a three clique,
but now the question is--is there a four clique in the graph.
So just to make sure that you understand the idea of this problem,
why don't you find the four clique--there is a four clique in this graph.
Find the four clique, add the node numbers that make up the clique together,
and enter the answer in the box.